the ratings are in and nobody watched
joe biden's joint address to congress
the other night
it wasn't quite nobody the ratings were
not quite as low as the oscar ratings
but they had almost the exact same
decline
year over year so now that we have the
numbers of the actual viewers
biden's joint session drew 22.6
million viewers that's across seven
major
networks that is a drop of 47
from the 43 million who tuned into
president trump's
first speech to a joint session across
those same networks
47 down in the ratings
from trump to biden because joe biden
you'll recall
is the most popular president in u.s
history with the most
votes and the greatest and everybody
just loves them so much kind of weird
how the numbers don't show it i'm
michael and also the michael knowles
show
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from old schooled
who says the one thing that the
presidential address had going for it
was that they had better actors than the
oscars did
that is not fair that was not anthony
hopkins one of the great living actors
he won the academy award but he did have
the good sense not to show up so i
suppose you're right
the the uh the comparisons between the
oscars and the joint session
uh very very profound
and i think it gets to the acting the
theater that we're all seeing play out
in front of us
in terms of our government
and the difference between as we talked
about yesterday the way the government
really works and the way the government
is supposed to look on paper
pretty big gap between those two
when you want to keep a nice strong gap
between you and the outside world
ring is the great way to deal with it
when i go on the road i am
so pleased that sweet little alisa and
cute little june can be safe
and can know who is outside the front
door before they open that front door
you gotta love a ring with ring you can
see and speak to whoever is at your
doorstep
whether you are in the living room
whether you are at your office down the
street
whether you are on a beach on the other
side of the world
it's really easy to install you can do
it yourself they've got a whole ring of
security that you can
that you can install it it makes you
feel like you're living in the future
this is why i like this as a
housewarming gift to my friends because
you know it's super cool and futuristic
and
not that expensive so it's a really
great housewarming gift when you're the
one buying
it too not just when you're the one
receiving it uh it's a terrific product
do not wait you can get a special offer
on the ring welcome kid at ring.com
knowles canada las this comes with rings
video doorbell 3 and chime pro this is
the perfect way
to start your ring experience go to
ring.com slash
knowles can wlas ring.com knowles
the most popular president in u.s
history over
i think he got 500 zillion votes joe
biden he's so
people just love that guy and that is
why they don't
tune in to watch him speak that is why
they don't seem to care
what he's doing that is why he doesn't
even seem
like an entity he seems like the absence
of an entity
because because the democrats are so
popular that's why they've got to kick
you off of
the internet if you ever question any of
their plans or any of their claims
because of how popular and in control
they are they're so
popular they're so in control of of the
narrative they're so in control of the
science
that they need to force you to wear 17
000 masks and if you don't they're going
to throw you off of
your airplane or they're going to throw
you out of a business or they're not
going to let you travel and they're not
they're not going to let you do anything
because of how
how in control they are and if by the
way if you want to pass an election
integrity bill in georgia
they are going to pull all of their
corporate money out
and then the congress is going to try to
steal the power to conduct elections
from the states
you know because of how popular they are
right right you know in new york
we've just had the reapportionment of
congressional districts new york just
lost
a congressional seat you know because of
how popular their policies are and how
everyone's flocking to new york
and flocking to california or is it the
opposite
is it that everyone is fleeing those
places with their terrible governments
and coming here new york is a great
place just in terms of the
location the history of new york the
greatest city greatest state in the
world
but i can't live there anymore many
people can't live there anymore people
are leaving that place
going to other places same thing with
california natural beauty
cannot be matched in california but
people are fleeing california in droves
and moving to places that maybe don't
have quite the same natural beauty
but they've got freedom and normal
people and the traditional american way
of life and that's what we want
new york lost its congressional seat by
89 people
you know they do the census they figure
out how many people there are then they
apportion the congressional seats
they came up 89 people short bill
mcmorris
at the washington free beacon tweeted
out an
interesting observation about this if
new york banned abortion for just seven
hours and 25
minutes in 2019 it would still have its
congressional seat
it's an amazing thing to think about
when you consider the issue of abortion
which new york celebrates you'll
remember when andrew cuovid
decided to sign the new abortion law
that allows people to kill their babies
up until the moment of birth
he said this is so wonderful we're going
to light the freedom tower up in pink
to celebrate all the girls we're going
to kill now through abortion
if they had had a slightly less
bloodthirsty view of abortion a slightly
less celebratory view
for seven hours and 25 minutes they
would still have their congressional
seat
because because we think about these as
separate there's women's reproductive
health and abortion
and and then there's the people no the
the people
got into this world by being born and so
if they're not born you don't get the
people
there are real effects to these policies
although sometimes it's a little bit
delayed
the conservative consolation is that
reality will reassert itself to some
degree in the end
that is the one thing we can hope for we
it might take a very long time we might
have to work very hard to do it
but eventually there is a reassertion of
reality you're seeing this now
even with the devout catholic joe biden
joe biden positions himself as a devout
catholic
he fundamentally disagrees with the
church's teaching and
disobeys the church's teaching on very
important matters notably life
which according to pope saint john paul
ii is not just
one issue among many it's not like well
look i agree with the church on
tax cuts but i disagree with the church
on abortion
and okay i guess we'll take it or leave
it no life is not one issue among many
is the prerequisite
for all of the other rights joe biden
fundamentally opposed with that that is
not permissible
that's why he was denied communion on
the campaign trail a couple years ago
now the u.s council of catholic bishops
is considering
holding joe biden to account threatening
to
withhold the eucharist that is to
excommunicate him prevent him from
receiving communion
this is a very good thing
this is not simply a punishment to
attack joe biden
this is an act of love the church is
teaching is that
if if you receive the eucharist in a
state of
grave mortal sin you are eating your own
damnation it is an act of love and
compassion by the church by the bishops
to withhold communion from joe biden
until he gets his life in order and gets
back in line
sometimes the bishops go a little kooky
sometimes the bishops
don't do their job sometimes the bishops
don't
have a spine i i spoke to a priest once
after i released my book reason uh
reasons to vote for democrats
i'm sorry i really got confused here
because usually when i talk about my
book i mention
my upcoming book speechless controlling
words controlling minds but
now i'm referring to my previous book
reasons to vote for democrats a
comprehensive guide i showed that to a
priest once he said
oh i think i might steal the idea and
and make my own book the wisdom of the
u.s council of catholic bishops
but here in the end the faith is
impelling them
to hold the line on life
hopefully we can pray that joe biden is
held on that point
because in other other derivations
other churches and ecclesiastical
community communities that have broken
away
you're not seeing that there's a story
out now that a southern baptist
is criticizing a methodist church
because they've got a
cross-dressing pastor
a that that's a very strange thing
because if you don't have that rock if
you don't have that grounding in reality
if you don't have that respect for
objective truth
then you're gonna fall away into very
kooky things and that's why you're
seeing a discrepancy
right now between what the american
political regime is telling us
about how they're supposed to behave and
about the nature of the government and
and
the way that things really are because
they have explicitly in their ideology
denied objective reality the left for
decades and decades now
has talked about how all we need to do
is construct narratives everything is
word
words words words and if we can redefine
the words we can redefine reality
what we're seeing is just peeking
through that's not quite true
joe biden the most popular president
ever well how come no one pays attention
to anything he says
oh the policies of the democrats are so
popular everyone loves them how come
people are fleeing their states
men really can be women well how how
come
so many people just don't think that so
there's uh we've mentioned this issue
the gender issue quite a lot on this
show
because while it afflicts only a very
small number of people as a
psychological matter
though increasingly so because it's a
social contagion especially among
younger people
but the reason that we talk about it is
because
the left is spending a lot of time and
energy and money on this issue and the
reason they're doing that is because if
they can redefine
nature if they can liberate themselves
even from the bonds of nature
then there is no limit to their
political project and that has always
been the point is to totally
revolutionize
society so now they're no longer even
arguing that adults should be able to
mutilate themselves
to better accord with their delusions
they're now saying that we should do
this to children as well
and when the republicans have pushed
back and said no we're not going to do
that
very popular laws pushed by republicans
to say you can't castrate your kids
that's child abuse we're not going to
let you do it
well what is the left saying if you
don't permit that
then you are abusing children you're
killing children ellen page now goes by
elliott page this actress
says the backlash right now is so
intense
but the rhetoric coming from anti-trans
activists
and anti-lgbtq activists
namely people who have two eyes and
recognize that men are not women
it's devastating these bills are going
to be responsible for the death of
children
it's that simple okay i want to take
this argument on
head on because i think very often
people will write in
from the left and they'll say you just
don't understand this issue michael
you're straw manning this issue
sure men and women are different but
some people have this awful affliction
and if you don't indulge their fantasies
then you're killing them because they're
going to be depressed and suicidal
what about anorexics what about people
who are dangerously thin
but believe that they are fat
that's their truth that's their that's
their self-perception that's their
identity
they're fat people trapped inside of
thin people's bodies
right and if we don't indulge their
delusion they're going to be very sad
and depressed and upset you're literally
killing them
if you don't allow them to destroy their
bodies
what's the difference they're both body
dysmorphic disorders
this is actually what paul mchugh the
doctor who helped to pioneer the
transgender surgery at johns hopkins
university which was the institution
that pioneered
the gender ideology this is what he
concluded in the 70s he said the surgery
doesn't really do anything to help
people doesn't necessarily hurt but it
doesn't
as a psychological matter it obviously
hurts their physicality but it doesn't
it doesn't help them so he stopped doing
it you know who else was at johns
hopkins
university dr john money a sick
pervert who was totally bought in on
gender identity theory
and destroyed a young boy's life because
he as a little baby
mutilated the boy's genitals to make him
look more like a girl and conducted
heinous experiments on him
and both he and his brother developed
horrible
disorders and ultimately both killed
themselves
on the altar sacrificed on the altar of
this insane theory
i discussed this at great length
actually in my upcoming book
what's it called speechless controlling
words controlling minds available now
for pre-order
horrible horrible things perpetrated in
this name
on a false sense of compassion there is
nothing compassionate about indulging
the anorexics delusions
and no amount of emotional manipulation
will will convince me that it is
there's another argument on the gender
theory which is this
yes men and women are different and
yeah that's not going to change reality
but these these men who think they're
women
are they're just caught in this
condition and there's no way out of it
and so it's better for them it's much
better for them
if they can mutilate their bodies to
look more like the other sex
before puberty sets in that's the
argument that
the actual strong argument for
castrating kids
relatively strong argument for
castrating kids is that
if you allow puberty to set in it's
going to be very difficult to mutilate
their bodies to look more like the other
sex
so you've got you actually have to do it
before
they're grown up before they have
developed their faculties of reason
totally
otherwise they're going to miss the
chance and you're going to be
responsible
you bigoted closed-minded conservatives
you're going to be responsible
for killing people later on because you
wouldn't mutilate them when they were
kids
i see the quasi-logic of that argument
parents make decisions for kids
right and they make some decisions for
kids because the kids are not old enough
to make those decisions themselves and
so the parents need to decide
to castrate the kids but we're not just
talking about
whether the kid is going to eat broccoli
or cheetos for dinner
we're not just talking about is the kid
going to learn violin
or guitar we're not just talking about
is he going to play football or baseball
we are talking about sexual decisions
for children and we are talking about
permanent
sexual decisions for children and it
raises this question someone wrote in
to me caitlyn burns who's written for
vox and msnbc
says by 18 the permanent effects of
natal puberty have set in so the state
has effectively made
decisions about their body without
giving adolescents any choice at all
any choices so the children need to have
choice
about sexual decisions and permanent
sexual decisions of that
but they're children they don't have
free choice
if this woman's argument or man i don't
know there i think there might be a
trans transgender issue in this case i
don't know much about this person
but if this argument is correct why do
we have age of consent laws
why what's the point of an age of
consent law
the argument for an age of consent law
is that kids are too young to make
any sexual decisions much less permanent
ones
if we are now saying that children have
the right to
mutilate their genitals castrate
themselves
surely you would have to abolish age of
consent laws so i pointed this out this
is a very basic
argument and of course the disingenuous
left what do they do whenever you
whenever you make a
a point like this they say well you what
stop sexualizing children
you're you're trying to get rid of age
of consent laws uh no
they don't really think that they're
just trying to get a cheap shot in no
quite the opposite
i'm trying to make it illegal to have
these surgeries
because this is extraordinarily
disordered and it's child abuse
and i don't think that children have
free agency
and i don't think that we should
sexualize children in the way that the
left has done
in a systematic way for decades
beginning with the bizarre
fantasies of wilhelm reich moving on to
the sick
child sexual experiments of dr john
money who
was that doctor at johns hopkins who
would who would have these two brothers
simulate sex
strip take photos of it all in the name
of some sort of perverted science
the the sexualization of children that
we saw in the early essays of bernie
sanders
in alternative newspapers in vermont who
would talk about how we need
children to become accustomed with to
their sexuality and experiment with one
another seriously it's in there
i mentioned it in my upcoming book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds yelping after
these are two totally different visions
and there's no compromise between those
things
okay and i think we're beginning to see
as the leftist narrative gets so insane
that you've got left-wingers arguing for
the
total sexualization of children to make
permanent sexual decisions
and the vast majority of people who look
at that and say man whatever that is i'm
out
whatever that is i don't want it you're
seeing
that break down now how did we get this
far
how on earth did the country get to the
point that we are seriously having
this debate there is a cuban refugee
spoke at the gop convention
this past year who has come out and he's
he's said in a recent interview
that the reason for this and he doesn't
want to sound hyperbolic but he knows a
thing or two about the subject
is that america has already swallowed
communism's poison pill take a listen
as we just heard here rnc convention you
had talked about
how people in cuba had swallowed the
communist
poison pill have americans swallowed the
communist
poison pill not only they have swallowed
the digestion it
listen to the media they're no longer
objective
you can tell how much they hate this
country look at our age
our academia our kids are not being
they're indoctrinated they're taught
that america is a bad country
that with a bunch of racists that we're
bad people and we have to pay back
if this country was racist i wouldn't be
here
if this country was a racist country
most of us wouldn't be here because even
some people in your family came from
another country
so he's speaking just from this personal
experience where he says
i've seen what's happened to my old
country and now i'm seeing what's
happening here
there is a lot to be said for this
you know the the left always says oh you
whenever you talk about marxism or
communism you crazy right wingers you're
just conspiracy theorists you've got a
tin foil hat on no no of course not
marxism has long festered in this
country in various places
in higher education in our institutions
whitaker chambers in that excellent book
witness helped make reagan into a
conservative he said
that communism is the great alternative
faith of mankind
which began in the garden of eden when
the serpent said ye shall be his gods
that is what we're when we're talking
about upending the whole system
abolish the police which is really just
a
euphemism for destroying the entire
justice system right the police are the
physical representations of the system
of law and order and justice
so when you abolish the police what
you're really saying is
abolish the whole system and the left
says the system is rotten to the core
founded the whole country was founded to
preserve slavery that's nicole hannah
jones
from the new york times the 1619 project
so you got to get rid of the whole thing
but we can't just even liberate
ourselves from politics and tradition
and society in our country we have to
liberate ourselves from nature and if a
little boy wants to be a little girl you
we have it in our power we shall be as
gods we will chop up that kid's genitals
to make him
look like a girl that is that's the
actual argument being made by these
people
and the the persuasive aspect of that
argument
is that we have total agency we want to
be totally in control we want to be
totally free
even a lot of right wingers buy into
that kind of idea
but it's based on a false anthropology
it's based on a false understanding of
human nature
that we're born into this world
primarily with rights and entitlement
rather than primarily with obligation
and duty and gratitude for our forebears
it's it's based on the false
anthropology that we own our bodies and
we can do whatever we want and true
freedom is is being able to
mutilate yourself or take a bunch of
drugs or or pursue any sort of vice you
want
the idea that true liberty is
licentiousness our founding fathers knew
the opposite was true
but this poisonous idea
has infected our institutions do not
forget
that the father of the new left one of
the most famous
marxist philosophers in the last hundred
years
worked for the cia or worked rather for
the precursor to the cia the office of
strategic services his name was herbert
marcuzza
herbert marcuzza it came to fame during
the
the rise of critical theory in the
frankfurt school
a critical theory is a very simple
theory the theory is to criticize
but it it followed from marx's
proclamation that we ought to pursue the
ruthless criticism of all that exists
it's a brilliant academic theory because
what it involves is opening up this
fallen world
which is obviously rife to criticism to
this ruthless assault
that ultimately can deconstruct society
marcus is the architect of political
correctness in many ways
he he wrote a very famous essay in the
60s called
repressive tolerance about how true
tolerance means you've got to shut down
conservatives and censor them and you've
got to encourage left-wing voices
marcus a revolutionary in society
and marcusa worked for the precursor to
the cia he worked for the federal
government not just during world war ii
which makes some sense because we were
teaming up with joseph stalin to fight
the nazis
but even after world war ii whitaker
chambers
details at length about how explicit
communists who were
doing work on behalf of the soviet union
were working at very high levels of the
state department
alger hiss most notably one of the only
politicians who actually believed
whitaker chambers and went after alger
his
richard nixon and the left never forgave
him for it
and the institutions would not not allow
him to remain in power
for very long well
today we are seeing the effects
of long festering poisonous ideologies
at our government institutions most
notably the cia
i woke up today and i saw that the cia
had tweeted something
should a should the nation's most famous
spy agency be tweeting in general
probably not
but it got worse it wasn't just that
they sent out a tweet
it was what they tweeted
there was no substantive difference
between the video that the cia tweeted
this morning
and the most ridiculous diversity
and inclusion training manual from the
most crazy leftist at the wokest
corporate boardroom or university take a
listen
i used to struggle with imposter
syndrome but at 36
i refuse to internalize misguided
patriarchal ideas of what a woman can or
should be i am tired of feeling like i'm
supposed to apologize
for the space i occupy rather than
intoxicate people with my effort
my brilliance i am proud of me full stop
my parents left everything they knew and
loved to expose me to opportunities they
never had
because of them i stand here today a
proud first generation latina
and officer at cia
[Music]
i'm so glad to hear that our spies
are no longer suffering from imposter
syndrome
that's that's good could you imagine if
those
spies felt like imposters
oh no that would be terrible for our
espionage apparatus
the left especially has long made an
argument to disband the c.i.a
because they'll say oh you know the cia
it put down communist revolutions in
latin america and it propped
up strong men in certain places that
advanced our interests and we need to
none of that i find persuasive at all
the cia has done there have been plenty
of
cia agents and operatives who have done
excellent work over the years
after watching that video i am prepared
to disband the cia
let's do it let's go we've clearly this
organization has outlived its usefulness
it's always had some dodgy connections
going back at least to marcusa but i we
gotta
we've it's enough that's enough when the
central intelligence agency which has a
lot of power in this country
which exerts a lot of influence even
over electoral politics
as we saw with the
[Music]
interference that they engaged in with
the trump administration
names like eric charmela come to mind
the cia has a lot of power they've got a
lot of power in the shadows
and they have now adopted as they are
told us this morning
a very very radical ideology
the ideology of radical liberation
the ideology that posits that there is
such a thing as a patriarchy
which needs to be overthrown an ideology
which posits
that people ought to embrace pride the
queen of all
vices now considered the greatest virtue
according to the left
the ideology that says that we must
embrace our
racial identity as the most important
and sexual identity as the most
important aspects of who we are
absolute poison for this country
that is now being pushed not even
secretly by our nation's
one of our nation's most secret agencies
it's being pushed right out in the open
a total takeover marcuzza must be giddy
he must be dancing from the afterlife as
he looks up
at what is happening here at the cia and
in the united states
all of the institutions have been
infected by this thing
there is a professor video just leaked
professor at cypress college
in southern california be rating
a student during fake zoom school
because the students suggested that the
cops are heroes
i think cops are heroes and they have to
have a difficult job but we have to have
all of my life
oh i i'm not i mean i'd say a good
majority of them you have bad people in
every business and every
yeah yeah wait wait wait police officers
have committed atrocious crimes and have
gotten away with it and have never been
convicted of any of it
and i say the person who has family
members
who are police officers yes
i i understand um and
this is what i believe this is my
opinion and this is you know not popular
to say but
uh i do support our police we have bad
people and the people that do bad things
should be brought to justice i agree
with that but i think that
uh i say i'm saying it again they
haven't
well i agree with you on that point of
they should right so what is your bottom
line point you're saying police officers
should be revered
viewed as heroes on tv
shows with children i think they are
heroes in a sense because they come to
your need and they come and help you
what can i vote for this kid for he this
is terrific stuff
because he's suffering with great
patience which is a virtue
through this absolutely empty-headed
professors diatribe against the police
and what's her argument she says
the police some police have done bad
things
and they and they've gotten away with it
uh true
you know who else has done bad things
and gotten away with it criminals
criminals have done that and yet what
the left does now is castigates all
police and assumes that
whenever police use force of any kind
that that's evil and wrong and what do
they do they exalt
criminals they just spent a year
exalting criminals
whenever a criminal does anything it's
well it's because the system made them
do it's really because the cops made
them do it probably
totally upside down that's what's being
taught
that's indoctrination but education
indoctrinates that's their synonyms okay
it's education is coercive it tells
people what to think
that is what is being taught that is
what's being taught at the universities
at the colleges that's what's being
pushed in our government agencies that's
what's being pushed in corporate board
rooms
it's the whole apparatus here it's so
crazy on this racial theory
that joy behar a very white woman
just lectured senator tim scott on the
view
because he apparently doesn't understand
systemic racism
tim scott he he does not seem to
understand
and a lot of them don't seem to
understand the difference between
um a racist country and
a systemic ra and systemic racism they
don't seem to get the difference yes
maybe it's not a racist country maybe
americans
the majority are not racist but we live
in a country with systemic racism we
discussed it this week again
already about housing and about
education
and and and all of the things that are
important to people
and um and and the fact that tim scott
cannot acknowledge this
is is is appalling how can you go out
there
and say that when you just said two
minutes ago that you were the
the object and the the victim of
discrimination
and then he says that this is not a
racist country at least acknowledge
that there is systemic racism that's
what i wanted to hear from him and he
didn't say it
i'm not saying it's a racist country but
at least acknowledge it's a racist
country what joy behar is doing right
here is doublethink
she's espousing two contradictory ideas
at the same time which george orwell
described beautifully in 1984.
she's saying the country isn't racist
sure that's fine but the system is
racist
so the amer america not racist the
american system is racist
if the system is racist then the thing
is racist then the thing that the system
describes is also racist they're the
same thing
it's like when the left says there's a
difference between sex and gender okay
what's the difference
sex is biological and gender is socially
constructed okay well if it's socially
constructed and people have a
disagreement between the two let's just
reconstruct that because it's all social
well no it's got a biological basis okay
so gender's got a biological basis now
sounds a lot like sex
and they say wow you just don't get it
you're not smart enough no i think
the people who are thinking
systematically about these things just
recognize that you can't hold
contradictory ideas
at the same time and and maintain your
coherence before we get to the mailbag
which is going to be great i have to i
have to commend senator ted cruz not
just because i host a podcast with him
he had an excellent article in the wall
street journal
your woke money is no good here senator
cruz
is turning away corporate pac money he's
made millions of dollars from corporate
pacs over the years
corporations donate to all sorts of
candidates he is now saying
that the gop has got to recognize that a
real threat in this country comes from
the corporations it's not just
the big government versus the private
sector it the corporations are
some of the institutions that have gone
totally poisonous
and in many ways they're leading the
cultural charge cruz is saying i'm not
taking any more money from them
and i encourage all other republicans to
do it too read the article
send it around and please help that
pressure campaign
the gop has got to stop shilling for
these woke
corporations that hate our way of life
and want to destroy our american
political tradition by the way as i'm
sure you all know
the daily wire has been growing like
crazy not only
did we move the whole company across the
country we also released our first
feature film
we struck up a movie deal with gina
carano we
launched a new talk show hosted by
candace owens all of that within
just the past six months i love
nashville i'm so glad that i'm here now
my only regret we didn't come sooner
all of us here at the daily wire would
like to express our gratitude to you
the audience for making all of this
possible we want to continue to include
you in our future plans
every single day on this show we talk
about a lot of terrific products and
services from sponsors
that i love and use uh we want to get to
know
you a little bit better so we can choose
our sponsors with you in mind
so please head on over to dailywire.com
knowles fill out my audience survey tell
us a little more about yourself
to sweeten the whole deal those of you
that complete the survey
will be entered to win a 1 000 gift card
could we hold on we got to pause it here
can i enter to win this survey because
ben has told me that my check is in the
mail for about um
five years now so it'd be great if i
could win that thousand dollar survey
i'll
i'll check with the guys after the show
you can only take the survey once per
daily wire show so if you want to
increase your chances of winning
one thousand dollars go listen to ben
drew matt
get access to their surveys as well head
on over to my survey link
the best survey link by far not even
close dailywire.com
knowles also get ready to stream the
latest episode of candace coming out
tonight
dave rubin is going to be on the show
it's going to be a lot of fun head on
over candace 9 pm eastern 8 pm central
at the daily wire
save 25 with code candace we'll be right
back with a lot more
welcome back to my absolute favorite
time of the week
the mailbag first question up from eric
good day michael i have a relationship
question for you
my girlfriend and i live together in
toronto and she would like to go visit
her grandparents
i have no problem with her doing this
because i know what her family means to
her and i like her family as well
the issue is that her grandparents are
covid crazy
and they would make my girlfriend and i
quarantined for two weeks
stopping us from exercising and picking
up our own groceries they even think we
should double mask
outside my girlfriend and i had a
disagreement regarding whether i will go
along with
that with what they want us to do i'm
quite tired of being a pushover and i
would like to stand up for myself if
someone wants to alter my life in a way
that i think is unjustified i understand
that i'm the one being harsh in this
situation
i haven't made up my mind i'm just
trying to figure out what is the least
bad decision
thank you so much and love the show i
sympathize with you
however you have put yourself in a very
weak position you have left yourself
open to your girlfriend's family telling
you what to do
because you are not married to your
girlfriend
that's the problem you're living with
your girlfriend a lot of people do that
these days i'm
not even it's a separate issue
but if you live with your girlfriend but
you are not married
to your girlfriend then in some ways you
get the benefits of
being married but in some ways you don't
one of the benefits of being married is
that you have the stature to be the head
of your household
and to call the shots within reason
but if you're not married you don't have
that stature
and you you don't have any credibility
when you're trying to
tell your wife's family that you're
going to run your own family and you're
going to
you know decide how best to react to
these things
so my first advice to you is get married
if you're already living together just
get married and then you'll have a lot
better stature and you you will avoid
these sorts of pitfalls
in the meantime
some of it depends i suppose just from
if you're thinking about the risk
calculation here
have your girlfriend's grandparents
gotten vaccinated
has your have you guys gotten vaccinated
i you know i
i'm with joe rogan on this i'm i'm not
clamoring out to go get the vaccine if
i'm a young healthy person
but likewise i don't i don't think
you're going to grow a tail in the third
eye
who knows i mean these are just risk
calculations you're making
i would defer even even if i were
married
i would try to come to a compromise that
is patient
and reverent toward your girlfriend's
grandparents because they're not going
to be around forever
and you don't want to create a situation
where
your girlfriend doesn't get to see your
grandparents
i wouldn't totally roll over but the
issue is
you you've left yourself in the position
to be a pushover
because you have not stepped up to
actually lead your household by getting
married before you move in so
i'm i'm not saying you're the only guy
to do this basically everyone does this
these days but
you can fix the problem by stepping up
and actually leading your household
from matthew first of all love the show
thank you second
what led you to christianity and if you
were able to elaborate on catholicism
keep up the good work and fight the good
fight
it's a it's a five-year story but i'll
i'll try to
compact that because i mentioned this on
the tim pool show the other night
and some people writing in said i wish
you had spoken about this
you know at greater length i was an
atheist for about 10 years i
but this started to crack down by the
end i was exposed to
the arguments for the existence of god
and
the quasi arguments against the
existence of god i actually don't think
there really are
arguments against the existence of god i
was first
introduced to the ontological argument i
later encountered other arguments for
the existence of god
they are persuasive they simply are
persuasive
we can go through those arguments i mean
i would just recommend going through for
you know the ontological argument i
really get a kick out of
some people don't find it convincing the
argument is basically god is the
greatest
is the maximally great being by
definition it's better to exist than not
to exist therefore god must exist
it's it's more complicated and
persuasive than that but that's the gist
of it
some people don't find that persuasive
there are many other good arguments for
god
notably the ones uh described by saint
thomas aquinas
arguments from cause contingency
perfection the arguments are just
simply better than the arguments against
god the best one against
god i guess is the problem of suffering
and the problem of pain it's known as
the odyssey
but the suffering does not really make
an argument one way or the other right
suffering is
is uh a fact of the world but actually
you can i think you can make a stronger
argument
for the existence of god beca through
suffering then against the existence of
god and notably for christianity which
involves incarnation and atonement okay
so there's the existence of god what
about christianity you've got to deal
seriously
with the person of christ and you can't
just say well there are lots of
different religions you know
kind of but first of all there are the
non-theistic religions hinduism
and buddhism but they don't really have
a systemic
systematic theology so that doesn't make
quite as much sense then you've got the
three major theistic religions judaism
christianity
and islam judaism
rejects the person of christ so you've
got to deal there with the person of
christ is christ who he says he is
islam is a a heresy of
a reading of islam a reading rather of
christianity
that comes from other heresies that were
going on at the time muhammad actually
met with very famously met with a
heretical christian monk
before he launched the religion of islam
i don't mean any disrespect to muslims
when i
when i say this is a christian heresy
but that that is the history of the
development of that religion
now you might say well but that's
nevertheless it's the true religion okay
i'm just telling you where it comes from
so in any of those cases when you're
dealing with the
theistic religions you have to deal with
this person of christ
and it just seems to me as c.s lewis
said he's either got to be one of the
three l's i'll even take it out further
to a fourth l
he's got to be a liar a lunatic
a legend or the lord
either he's a liar and he he's not who
he says he is but then
you have to account for the miracles you
have to account for the resurrection
which has
500 eyewitnesses and you've got to
account for the way that he speaks which
just doesn't seem like a liar and a liar
to what end he ends up getting crucified
he's either a lunatic right he's just
saying crazy things but again
how does he persuade all these people to
follow him when you read what he says
does he sound like a lunatic to you or
does does he sound actually like the
only sane person in a lunatic world
or he is a legend did he just not exist
at all that there have been some kooks
who have tried to say that in the 19th
and 20th centuries but
it just doesn't hold up the the evidence
for the existence of christ
and for what he did is just so good it's
so much better than for basically any
other
figure of the era so i don't think that
works then you've got to get to the lord
is he the lord it would seem that he is
hallelujah hallelujah next question
from rob sadly my daughter was singing a
disney song tonight at dinner
jasmine's song in aladdin speechless
thankfully i
[Music]
thankfully i've already pre-ordered my
signed copy of your upcoming speechless
controlling words controlling mine's
available for pre-order
for now do we get a ding for that if i
didn't
i guess we i don't know i didn't that
wasn't my plug
but that was a really that plug was so
seamless too i'm going to take
notes on how to make a transition that
seamless from drew
hey michael my name is drew i'm 26 and i
watched the episode of backstage
and notice that in the chamber there are
two symbols next to the flags called
fascis
this is in the the house of
representatives i didn't know what it
was so i looked it up
and it sounds a whole lot like fascist
symbolism is there a good reason the
united states has such a symbol in the
chamber of congress thanks
yes the fascist is a an ancient symbol
that goes back to ancient rome
you see it in greece you've seen it all
throughout the history of
many countries including the united
states
fascism takes this idea of
the fascists like a bundling up together
and creates a political ideology out of
that but fascism is a modernist
political ideology this is why sometimes
when people call me a fascist
i like to point out that i am far too
reactionary
for fascism i am way more conservative
than the fascists are
because fascism it's difficult to pin
down george orwell famously said
that fascism now only has the meaning of
something not desirable everyone calls
everyone else a fascist
but there is an essay about fascism
written by benito mussolini the founder
of it the italian dictator and giovanni
gentile who is the philosopher who
helped him write that essay
and what it basically boils down to
is an atheist political ideology that
worships the state
the state comes above all other things
and that's about as specific as you can
get on what fascism is
so it takes this idea of the bundling up
of everybody
and just describes that as the state in
a way sort of like what joe biden said
the other day when he said
we the people are the government the
government are the people there's no
distinction between the two things
but in america we just don't believe
that we have a great separation of
powers between the federal government
the state governments
the people themselves and we also
believe that government is circumscribed
by god which fascism would not recognize
so
it's you know like many ideologies
it takes some aspect of
antiquity or some aspect of the
tradition and blows it up out of
proportion like chesterton said he says
that most
heresy is not the promotion of vice over
virtue it's the promotion of one virtue
to the exclusion of all the others from
paula
michael i never thought i would take
issue with you on anything
however i disagree with you on how we
look at those with gender dysphoria
i completely disagree that we have or i
completely agree rather that we have
only two sexes
but gender dysphoria is real and those
who suffer have to do what they have to
do to get through life
neither you or i can grasp what a person
with gender dysphoria must be going
through
on caitlyn she does not believe she is a
woman but you believe she's a woman
though if you're going to call her she
she believes she needed to make her
outside match her inside to continue to
go forward
read the mayo right up on gender
dysphoria this is not a perversion this
is a mental disorder keep up the good
work
thank you well we're getting a little
confused on our terms here
a perversion is just an an aberration an
abnormality a distortion
so if you say it's a gender disorder not
a perversion it you're
you're using synonyms here it is a
perversion and in this case
it pertains to sex the nature of sex
itself and so it's a sexual perversion
but yeah of course people who have this
rare psychological condition
perhaps they don't some of them think
that they are really the other sex but
perhaps some of them recognize no i know
i'm not the other sex but i just
have this mental problem where i think
where i
would very much would like to be blair
white has made this point blair white is
a famous
uh transgender uh right-wing type person
who was actually on my show in the early
days so
sure i i understand that and i recognize
that
it's very difficult and i imagine that's
a very difficult disorder to have
the question is what you've hidden here
is this line you say
she has to do what she has to do what
does that mean that's one of those
expressions like it is what it is well
no what is it
what does she have to do what is she is
she she or is she he
i'll go back to the example i used
earlier in the show
anorexics perhaps they know some of them
think they're too fat
perhaps some of them know they're not
too fat but they just have this disorder
where they really don't want to eat
because they want control or they really
want to be really really thin
or they have this perversion or this
disorder where they fetishize being very
very thin
and they have to do what they have to do
right
no no is it compassionate to indulge the
anorexic and say look you got to do you
have this difficult disorder i can't
imagine how hard that is so
yeah if you don't want to eat for a few
days you shouldn't have to eat
now you should you should you should
because it is objectively wrong and
disordered
and we should not encourage disorders we
should not subsidize disorders we should
not
incentivize disorders we should push
back against them
there is no evidence that
indulging this delusion is helpful to
the psychology of people with this
disorder
and even if there were the indulgence of
lies
is not justified because it makes p some
people feel good some of the time or
makes them
feel some kind of pleasure some of the
time that is not
a good argument i recognize the
heartstrings issue you want these people
to feel better
but i don't think that the indulgence of
lies makes them feel better and this
this is a fallen world and if we don't
cling to truth
if we search for comfort we might find
uh rather if we search for truth we
might find comfort in the end but if we
search for comfort we'll find neither
truth nor comfort
only soft soap and wishful thinking to
begin and in the end despair
c.s lewis says last question caleb says
michael big fan of the show
i love hearing about your new bundle of
joy i also recently had a baby and
seeing this anti-racist baby book
got me wondering how do i raise an
anti-communist baby here's how you do it
you set your phone or your speaker
right next to the crib and right as as
the baby is about to go to sleep at
night instead of putting on a noise
machine or something like that
you just turn not so loud you just tune
on the michael knowles show
that is a lullaby that is gonna that is
gonna raise a wonderful anti-communist
baby
that's the new lullaby that your child
is going to hear i wish you luck
congratulations on your baby i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 hey everybody this is andrew clavin
host of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin